no trips no concerts no visits
throughout the world drastic measures
are being imposed to combat the corona
virus millions must accustom themselves
to an ongoing state of emergency the
European Union is hunkering down borders
are closed for 30 days member states are
checking passports again at what used to
be open internal crossings every
government seems to be thinking of its
own people first even as leaders rattle
off Appeals for cross-border solidarity
so how are people reacting what
consequences will the emergency measures
have for our societies our topic today
Korona how should we handle this crisis
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome this week's show is a
bit different from usual our guests are
exclusively colleagues from DW because
here too we're working under
extraordinary new conditions trying to
counteract the spread of the corona
virus as far as possible and that's why
you also see us sitting much further
apart than we are accustomed it is my
great pleasure to introduce our guests
beginning with Thomas Sparrow he is a
political correspondent here at DW and
he says we need bold political decisions
but this is also a crucial time for
personal solidarity I'm also very glad
to welcome Kate Ferguson she's a
colleague from DW business and she says
leaders from the world of business and
politics need to be guided by the
principle of cooperation and not
competition and very glad to have with
us as well Barbara Moore she reports for
DW sport and she says it's not just
about professional sports with the
closure of the many small sports clubs
an important social support in everyday
life also breaks away for many people so
let me begin by asking all of you how
you personally are coping what the
biggest challenges are that you're
facing and perhaps also what you're
already missing Thomas I think something
that I'm particularly missing as a South
American journalist and also South
American citizen is probably hugs we're
very much used to to shaking hands to
having people and it's it has really
been a challenge for me to try and keep
this distance from other people and be
conscious that this is very important at
this time so on a very personal level I
would say that is something that I am
particularly missing I have obviously
tried to stay at home as much as I can
to try and be much more aware of what's
at stake as I said I think this is high
time for solidarity and I'm trying to
also make sure that's the case in my
personal life also at work wherever I am
it's not only about being selfish and
hoarding things it's about really
thinking about the other people as well
Barbara I have two kids at home nine and
11 years old and since Monday we are
doing home schooling with them so that's
of course a very new sister
instead I think it's it's working okay
so far but I'm not living in a community
with elderly people with actually one
child that has an immune disease so I'm
also very aware of me being responsible
for not infecting anybody else can you
just tell me how you explain this to a
child
luckily my kids are old enough to like
reflect a bit on the situation and then
of course it does help to say look this
neighbor Elsa she is older and we really
have to take care of her we have to
protect ourselves in order to protect
her and that makes it much easier if you
have a concrete example actually to
explain to kids okay
like Thomas I have a natural impulse to
hug that I've only realized her when
I've been denied the opportunity but
something that I personally have been
really struggling with is my own risk
assessment so over the past few weeks as
this crisis has been growing and we've
seen the disaster unfold in other
countries I've been questioning all of
my own decisions should I have met that
person for coffee a few weeks ago should
I be taking public transport
should I be leaving the house at all and
it's it's something that I am
continuously struggling with because
you're guided on one level by what
leaders are telling you to do but then
you have your individual responsibility
as well so I two trips that I cancelled
this month but it really took quite a
lot of thinking for me to come to that
decision Thomas I know that you've just
returned from Latin America what was the
situation there and how were people
there reacting there are fewer cases in
South America than what we're seeing
here in Europe especially in some of
European countries that are very badly
affected by all this so in South America
the situation is only just starting but
it has meant that political leaders are
taking decisions very early so in
particular in Colombia where I was
borders have been already closed people
have been told to stay at home it is
very difficult for Colombians to
actually stay at home in particular for
those who actually need to go out to
work or but probably haven't got that
safety net that you have in other parts
of the world so which is a very
difficult situation you go to
supermarkets and they are also empty not
something that I've been seeing from my
own family when they go and buy things
that's very difficult for them to get
what they want so South America is a bit
behind compared to to Europe and there
is a lot of concern that maybe South
America will
see in a few weeks what Europe is seeing
right now and that's why you also see
political decisions you can be critical
of them you can support them but there
are political decisions trying to
minimize the impact of the coronavirus
it's been said that Europe and the US
didn't use the time after China started
to wrestle with Korona that they did not
use their window of opportunity do you
think latin america is doing so and that
is the absolute key element there when
you look at what's being debated in
latin america it's exactly that saying
we need to be able to act now so not
when we have hundreds of cases but when
we have only a few cases if you see for
example the case of el salvador they
close the borders when they had zero
cases because it said we're not giving
this a chance we're not going to wait
until we have a hundred to start making
decisions and what you hear from many
people in latin america and also in
colombia in particular is it has to be
done before the situation gets very bad
you can't simply wait for a long time
Barbara even after concerts and trade
fairs had long since been cancelled
major soccer games in the Bundesliga and
also in the Champions League were still
being played in fronts of tens of
thousands of fans that is now over what
does that mean for football fans in
Germany including yourself yeah I think
this was actually a crucial point where
many people finally understood that
something serious is happening because
never before but just like like bigger
leaks all over the words suddenly shut
down and even now the euros being
postponed this is obviously a big thing
so I think this is more like an alarm
for everybody saying no it's really
really have this situation we have to
act but of course it's difficult for the
fans not only that teams aren't playing
that the leaks not playing but also for
those being active themselves because
also the smaller clubs are shut down and
you like you can't go to your fencing
cup to your gym class whatever but you
have to be creative and stay at home out
there because I am also a sports fan and
what I realized when all these events
started to get cancelled is that this is
above all a challenge that is not only
for politicians not only for world
leaders it is something that is
absolutely up to us as well to make
this doesn't spread any further and when
you see that clearly with sports when
you have all these events being canceled
when you're being told you really have
to make your own you have to participate
in a way that you reduce the impact of
this virus that's something that I
particularly saw when you when you have
events canceled conscious theaters but
also in particular sports which is
something very important for many people
around the world Kate when it comes to
wake-up calls were certainly getting one
from the stock markets as well they are
absolutely setting records as they
plummet what do you think is in store
for us and what's your personal feeling
as you watch these curves just fall and
fall and fall well I think if there's
one tiny good thing to come of this
crisis it's that the myth of our own
invulnerability has been completely
exposed both on an individual and on a
global level and when it comes to the
stock market we haven't seen as much
volatility since the Great Depression
and but I also think it's important to
separate what's happening on the stock
market with the experience of everyday
people it stocks always go up and down
they're likely to continue to be
volatile for as long as we have this
crisis because this is a public health
issue so it's completely unpredictable
but I think it's very important for
governments to act quickly and
decisively to shore up people's people's
lives and make sure their jobs are
secure in Germany so far has actually
done quite a good job of that by
implementing some policies so that if a
company wants to let somebody go and
because of the coronavirus instead of
actually firing them they will keep them
on the books but continue to give them
some pay and I want to come back to that
a little bit later on in the show but
first of all I'd like to take a look at
how some people living under lockdown
which we don't have yet
here in Germany but we may eventually
how some are proving especially creative
at dispelling fear and loneliness
fighting isolation by making music
together through the days of quarantine
they give each other courage as here in
Rome
[Music]
an Italian quartet gives a free open-air
concert not to a live audience but
rather live on Facebook and the Berlin
Philharmonic played Berio and Bartok to
an empty house music lovers were able to
livestream the concert into their living
rooms
[Music]
how much do we really need to be
together Thomas we saw in that in the
first sequence from Italy people out
there on their balconies and not only
there our balconies playing a big role
in Italy in Spain people are apparently
doing Fitness on their balconies with a
trainer on a rooftop instructing them do
you think things like that that we saw
things like what we saw in the report
are just temporary distractions or do
they actually help to build that sense
of solidarity that you were talking
about I absolutely think that they help
to build that sense of solidarity I
think you know in times of crisis around
the world you can have the worst out of
people but you can also get the best out
of people and these examples that we're
just seeing here are how people are
being very creative to try and make sure
that is very difficult a very bad
situation for many people can be an at
least a little bit improved in many
different ways this is something that
you also see in other parts of the world
by the way this is also you're also
starting to see right here in Germany I
saw something very interesting in recent
days of people asking to buy vouchers of
their favorite restaurants that they can
then redeem later on when the crisis has
been overcome I thought there was a
fantastic idea try and help your
favorite restaurant or your favorite
supermarket or a favorite shop they can
obviously not sell things now as they
would before but that's a way in which
you can help so I definitely think it's
high time for solidarity great thank you
Barbara in your opening statement you
said that the cessation of sporting
events would deprive many people of a
very important social support that they
need in a time like this so is there any
substitute for that in the virtual world
and how are sports fans coping yeah I
think there's a lot going on now like of
course with social media there's another
way to connect then again virtually this
is we have seen that in China already
people having challenges through their
widgets groups who can do more setups
and and and group sitting together or
even having a drink together just
virtually being connected and there's
actually also a lot on the market like
there is a
a program for bike riders you can
actually sit in the basement on your on
your on your bike and a fixed bike and
and be virtually connected and actually
at the moment live being riding against
other cyclists sitting in their basement
and doing the same so I think a lot of
these kind of alternatives are going to
come up now and we'll hopefully do some
substitution okay you said in your
opening statement that we need political
decisions that are very much based on
cooperation do you feel like we're
seeing that adequately and are people
paying attention I have to say I live in
Kreuzberg one of the central districts
in the city frankly at least until today
people there have not really fully been
adhering to the new rules
just yesterday I saw about 25 young men
playing a game of pickup soccer in a
local park very close together
definitely not social distancing very
sweaty do you think people have gotten
the message
well sabe I've seen similar scenes you
know on the way here for example but
what I think is really important for us
as journalists to do is to frame social
distancing as the ultimate act of
solidarity that it is so if one of us
here at the table were to become
infected without social distancing
within a month 244 people would be
infected as a result with social
distancing we can reduce that to four
and that message really needs to come
across so it is really great that we're
seeing these examples of community
spirit that's really heartening but
actually the best thing you can do to
save lives is to stay away from people
and we really need to hammer that home
but can you say it in response to an
additional question I just like to tack
on to that namely in regard to the
Chancellor's appeal what is that about
whatever because the Chancellor gave
exactly that message and she gave it in
language such as I have never heard her
use before very personal very urgent it
was the first time she's addressed the
German nation in this form since she has
taken power and she's been in power a
long time do you think that message is
going to be heard will it get through to
those people who need to hear
at those young men playing soccer in my
Park Malinda that was exactly what I was
planning to talk about that that speech
by Angela Merkel yesterday that address
on national television she normally does
those addresses only on New Year's Eve
on New Year's Day and this is the very
first time in her 15 years as Chancellor
that she gives such an address on
television and that just gives you an
idea of how urgent it is and how
important is that decisions are not only
made right at the top but that people
understand what you're just saying
Kate that this has to be done by all of
us and I agree with you totally
tarantella Merkel's message yesterday
was very clear it was human it was
authoritative it was very clear and I do
hope that people here in Germany will
understand that it's time for them to
act but it's not time for them to keep
playing football outdoors or taking
their kids to the playground it's really
time for all of us to understand that
this is a very big responsibility that
we have and when it comes to those
playing the park we can hope that if not
Angela Merkel also the head coach of the
national football team of Germany's
national football team has been has had
a speech yesterday going to the same
direction so maybe those still playing
football in the parks then would listen
to him at least and also follow the
rules on the other hand Kate we at the
same time are seeing shortages of things
like toilet paper as people essentially
get engaged in hoarding behavior and
even more serious is stockpiling of very
important medical goods including
breathing masks and hand sanitizer price
gouging by some people who've bought up
tens of thousands of bottles of hand
sanitizer what does that tell us about
how people are reacting to this crisis
and do you think we'll see more of it as
things get worse well as Toma said
earlier risking the very best and the
very worst of humanity you come out of a
crisis which is to be expected and here
in Germany we have a wonderful word to
describe this sort of panic buying
hamster cough which a colleague of mine
is appealing for us to install into the
English language like the rider rain
hamster hamstrung squirreling things
away and yeah we have seen a lot of that
but in in that address last night Angela
Merkel really did reassure people that
supermarkets would be stocked and that
really a big
issue for supply is actually people
panic buying the logistics chains are
solid at the moment and those cargo
trucks are not being stopped at borders
so we don't really need to have to worry
about that
speaking of borders let us dive a little
bit deeper into the subject of shortages
and the economic effects of this crisis
at the beginning of the week Germany
largely shut down its borders with
France Denmark Luxembourg Switzerland
and Austria officials claim that the
movement of goods won't be affected but
reality tells a different story
border checks are once again backing up
traffic as here on Germany's border to
France a microscopic virus is bringing
Europe to its knees the Union is
isolating itself the only ones allowed
in are those who work here or need to
stock up on necessities like medications
only trucks are allowed through without
checks but traffic is backing up at
border crossings like here in Kufstein
that in itself may lead to considerable
disruption to supply chains for now we
see no cause for worry but everyone
should act responsibly and take only
what they really need rest assured that
everything is being done to guarantee
adequate supplies yet even before
borders were closed supermarket shelves
were emptied all across Europe as here
in Britain and shortages of medicines
are expected over the coming weeks
this is the downside of globalization it
has many upsides but these are the
classic downsides can our basic needs be
covered Thomas let me address that
question to you can our basic needs be
covered and also in regard to the border
closures even the chief of staff of the
Commission President of the European
Union
has said border closures aren't going to
do a whole lot because the virus is long
since here in the individual member
countries of the European Union so
what's going on with these border
closures and will they imperil supply
well the hope is that it won't impair
all supply and there are guidelines
already in place to make sure that
essential goods like medicine for
example of food can indeed reach those
who need it the most I do agree that
border closures may not have a very big
effect but at the same time the goal of
all these measures including border
controls is to slow down the process of
the coronavirus make sure that's well
you've probably seen that flattening the
curve idea making sure that you spread
it as much as possible so they're all
health services at a national level but
also at a European level can cope with
this and maybe in this specific point
those border closures may have an impact
not a very big impact not an impact on
it's on their own but they can't help to
have an impact I do believe that Kate VW
and Daimler two of Germany's biggest car
companies VW in fact biggest car company
in the world are stopping production for
now is Germany and perhaps the world as
a whole about to slide into the worst
recession that we've seen since the
Great Depression of the 30s and you
mentioned it in the outset is Germany
with its so-called social market economy
pretty well equipped to handle this if
that is in fact what occurs yeah we most
likely are going to head into a severe
recession but it's what happens after
that so economists hope that they'll be
what's called a v-shaped recovery so a
very steep decline but then when when
this virus is is under control that
things will will improve very quickly
again but in order for that to happen
you need policies in place and so what's
happened here in Germany is a number of
measures have been introduced
ensure that things will continue
smoothly so one of them as you mentioned
was this quit a bite and this is a
benefit that short work short work yet
this is a benefit that applies to people
who would otherwise lose their jobs
because of in this case the coronavirus
instead of being fired they keep their
jobs on the books they no longer work
because they're not needed but they get
60% of their salary paid for by the
government and that is something which
typically works very well in in crisis
situations because it means that when
the crisis is over things can continue
seamlessly and they've also introduced
tax deferrals for companies struggling
and they are also offering unlimited
loans so they are doing a lot to ensure
that the recovery is as smooth as
possible Thomas if we look at the
situation in Europe as a whole we could
be forgiven for concluding that the
European Union is this only in name
we've seen very little solidarity in
terms of support for either the
suffering people or economies of Spain
of Italy is Brussels finally now waking
up a bit too late but they are waking up
what he saw at the beginning was
basically all the countries mostly
affected dealing on their own basically
trying to solve situation on their own
asking for Brussels for help and that's
why now for example you see Chancellor
Angela Merkel among gada European
leaders try to stress the fact that they
are working together to find solutions I
agree that that's absolutely necessary
but I do also think that that came a bit
too late that that help should have been
there much earlier when the crisis was
not as bad and not now when you have
thousands of cases in many different
European countries Barbera football also
losing millions in in forgone income
particularly problematic for the smaller
football soccer clubs is there any help
for them and what will be the
consequences of postponing these really
important matches like the European
football championship yeah I mean of
course we have to keep in mind that's
only like three to four percent of all
the football players worldwide earn as
much as the public thinks they do think
they do so for many it's actually a very
very fragile situation especially play
in Latin America or in Africa where yeah
contracts are like not as secure as they
are in Bundesliga for German clubs
actually the first have already asked
for quotes about the first like third
league clubs and Germany have they can
use the same measures as other companies
here in Germany but then it's it's as I
said it's very difficult a different
Worldwide's and I'm I'm afraid for
smaller clubs and also for women's
football for example that has been on
the rise recently finally number is
growing but structures extremely fragile
so I'm afraid they're gonna get some I
have to say it take some steps back ends
yeah start forward we're slowly coming
to the end of our discussion so I'd like
to take us back to something all of you
have said you've said in a crisis like
this we can see both the best and the
worst of people what do you think will
come out in the end our top our title
asks how we're handling the crisis do
you think as it's so often said in this
crisis we might find an opportunity to
perhaps change track or would you expect
that we may see selfishness prevail in
the end king
there'll be examples of both I have no
doubt but I do think that now and for
any countries perhaps but have no
coronavirus cases yet or very few this
is an opportunity to learn from the
experience of others and that has to be
the priority we've seen many medical
systems struggling because they've been
underfunded for decades do you think
that will change after this I can only
hope that political pressure increases
you know we have the huge case of so
many Americans who are uninsured in
their status within this crisis is
uncertain so you would hope that there
would be a drive for a change so we can
only wait and see
Barbara I think those people are
believing in solidarity they just have
to be louder and more presence to
encourage everybody else to support each
other I think in 10 or 15 years time
when we look back at this or at least
that's my hope we will look at those
scenes from the balconies in Spain and
and Italy and think that that was a very
good example that we also were able to
learn
from those act of selfishness because
this will not be the last crisis where
you will see the worst and the best of
humanity the Chancellor said yesterday
it's the worst crisis Germany has faced
since the Second World War I've
sometimes wondered whether later we will
see this as the kind of hiatus in
history the Second World War was for
many people thank you very much to all
of us for being with us today and I wish
all of you the best of health and I wish
the same to you dear viewers we hope you
stay healthy we are going to be taking a
break with to the point for at least
four weeks and we hope to see you after
that stay well
[Music]
you